I left university 10 years ago
that was the last time I procrastinated
the way I procrastinated going through this manifesto
let me tell you why
because why is this document gaslighting me?
Why do I feel like going through this document
is like having a conversation with an abusive partner
why do I feel like I'm
I'm being lied to in a relationship?
Okay, let's just do this
we gonna speak about the cost of living and the
financial sector
the first thing that I noted is they wanna cut VAT
on certain things that they deem essential items
nothing wrong with that
few other political
parties have proposed the same thing
they also said they wanna implement
the national health insurance Bill
why why didn't you do it already
anyway let me
let me just go to the next one
they do want to regulate the rental prices
but only for student accommodation
can we can we regulate it for everybody please?
We just we just want to afford a house like why
and then there's also
increase affordable rail and commuter transport
now I had a conversation
with my friend from Germany the other day
and she said that they pay €49
€49 and then they can use a bus or train
to go anywhere in the city
um I think anywhere across the
is the country or the city
I'm not sure
but it's 49 euros flat rate
can you imagine if all we did was
Pay 1,000 rand and all our
transportation was sorted out
you know how much we spend on
let me go to the next one
the next one is on transforming the financial sector
commercial banks have fucked us over left
right and centre
let's let's call a spade a spade
we know this already
whether it comes to different interest rates
depending on your race
or whether it comes to denying home loans
or denying the area that you're applying for
depending on your race
then there's also the issue of colluding
with a few other international banks
to lower the price of our currency
and screw the whole country over
this is our commercial banks
so obviously
we need a state bank because the commercial banks
are literally showing us the middle finger
every single year
they do not care about anybody except the wealthy
it's done it's not up for debate
if you don't know this
read a book
I'm not gonna have this conversation with somebody
commercial banks do not like anybody okay
except the rich
so we need a state bank
it's not up for debate
because the commercial anyway
so I don't have a problem with a N C saying hey
we need a state bank
my question is why the hmm
why is it not here
that's all I wanna know it's all I wanna why is it
there's some Other points here about having provinces
establish their own financial institutions
which Aah tricky but okay
here's my thing
what yoh I'm struggling so bad
Samantha Jansen said something very important
she said it in one of her videos
I'm actually gonna tag her
please go watch the video
she says something very important she says
why has there not been any new white political parties?
There's the d a
and then there's the Freedom Front plus okay, um
why have there not been any new white political parties?
There been new black political parties
every single election
why has there not been any new white political parties?
And the reason for that is
because White Monopoly Capital
has been able to remain comfortable
under the current government
they've been able to maintain the status quo
they've been able to hold onto the ill gotten gains
they've been able to maintain inequality
under the a N C government so
the a N C government
is a white people's government because
they've been living liquor under the a N C government
so all the hype from the media about er corruption
me me me me
the private sector is not complaining
the private sector doesn't have an issue
have you looked at the all share index?
We are the most unequal country on the planet
where do you think the wealthy side is sitting?
It's in the private sector so
I'm gonna stop here
I'm gonna stop here I'll come back and then cover
public healthcare and transport.
Also this manifesto is Kak.
Whoever wrote this manifesto,
arguably you and the d a
should get together and form a relationship.
You guys match made in heaven. Honestly,
it looks like a first year group project
made by all the lazy people in the class
nobody wanted to be with.
I'm I'm done.
I'm actually done.
This this this document is offensive.